[Music]
the principles of persuasion are a set
of psychological rules to influence
others originally there were six
reciprocity scarcity Authority
consistency liking and
consensus later a seventh principle was
added the first principle is reciprocity
it means that if you give something to
someone it makes them more open to being
influenced by you this is because we
don't like to feel that we owe someone
and so we want to return the favor to
clear our social
debt the second is scarcity when people
perceive something as rare or limited
they are more susceptible to persuasion
this is driven by our desire to possess
what others value and the fear of
missing out that prompts us to make
decisions the third principle is
Authority we often trust powerful people
and their perceived expertise we seek
their guidance particularly in
situations of uncertainty when we lack
Direction and need help from someone
else to make a difficult decision on our
behalf fourth is consistency we are more
likely to do something if it's
consistent with past Behavior this is
because we align our actions with
expectations to influence someone one
ask for small commitments first and
larger ones
later the fifth is liking people are
more willing to say yes to those they
are fond of to make people like you find
common interests be friendly and give
genuine
compliments the sixth is consensus
humans are inherently social they want
to conform to the group social proof can
therefore persuade Ade people to commit
to something they otherwise
doubt psychologist Robert chalini who
came up with the six rules later added
another one Unity accordingly people are
more influenced by those who share their
beliefs values and
experiences so do you think you
understand the principles then meet Jane
a young entrepreneur who after learning
about them established a success
uccessful lemonade business follow her
story and try to tell us which
principles she uses and in what
sequence to start her business Jane
first needs to get funding to do so she
offers free samples to potential
investors when she later presents her
business idea those who tried her
product are now more likely to hear her
out on her first week of business Jane
produces just enough to satisfy some
customers but pretends to run out before
everyone gets what they lined up for by
doing so she creates a sense of
exclusivity Jane then starts to Showcase
her top customers encourages positive
reviews invites key opinion leaders to
visit her shop and hosts a local band to
play on
Sundays once her products are popular
customers can't get enough of them to
ensure she's not losing anyone she
distributes paper cups to those in line
those that take the cup are then more
likely to wait for what they came
for despite all that success when Jane
tries to open a savings account she gets
laughed at so she Partners up with her
supplier to appear trustworthy enough to
get the job
done to strengthen her business Jane
listens to her customers and shows
interest in the community as a result
people will feel more connected to her
company and stay loyal despite the
competition now tell us in the comments
below which of the seven principles Jane
applied and in what
order note that if these ideas aren't
enough to get the job done here is one
last piece of chini's advice when we ask
someone to do us a favor we will be more
successful if we Pro provide a reason
even if the reason is utterly
unreasonable what do you think will
knowing these rules help you resist
manipulation and is it morally
acceptable to use them for personal gain
share your thoughts in the comments
[Music]
below this video was brought to you by
short.com
shortform offers premium summaries of of
non-fiction books if you want to dig
deeper say on the principles of
persuasion but have no time get short
form summary where you can highlight key
points take personal notes share your
favorite quotes and even challenge your
understanding with
exercises the short form Library
includes many topics from the fields of
Education parenting and psychology short
form superpower guides cover a new books
key ideas every week in simple language
plus include smart commentary and
Analysis
short form is constantly adding new
features such as short form AI a browser
extension that summarizes everything
across the internet with a click of a
button short form is a really easy way
to learn about some of life's most
important ideas to get started visit
short.com Sprouts or click on the link
in the description you will get a free
trial of unlimited access plus a 20%
discounted annual
subscription
if you found this helpful check out our
other videos and subscribe if you want
to support our work join us on